welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz this is another
installment of the 15 minutes
with a mentor series where we spend
time with some of the mentors from
inside the recruitment mentors community
and ask them
seven questions in 15 minutes i'm
excited to be joined by caroline today
but before we go into the questions
caroline if you could introduce yourself
for those that may not know who you are
and then we'll get into it sure thanks
teaching
my name is caroline i've been in
recruitment for this is my 15th year
i had a job change in
2020 and i joined oscar associates of
their contract
director uk and europe amazing
so i want to know from you then first
question is
what was your biggest challenge in 2020
how did you overcome it and what did you
learn from it
sure so biggest challenge as many people
will agree
you know we're plunged into a pandemic
um
you know and the working from home
culture wasn't established wasn't
embedded in
many of our businesses so that just
brought a whole new set of challenges
whether like myself you're a working
parent or
you know you live on your own everybody
felt
the everybody felt the challenge and
very tough to get used to those first
few weeks back in march 2020
um i guess how um
i overcame it as as a leader um at my
business at the time
was you know getting used to these tech
tools straight away
making sure that you've got that team
interaction from the off
and you know you know not really sharing
the problem and just getting it sorted
so that they weren't losing out on face
time with you
and i think for me as well how i
overcame
was made a lot more noise about the
future goals future ambitions of the
team
so everything felt more real so making
more noise about that
was um was definitely an idea
you know accepting that you know there's
going to be flat days
there'll be really high days and we need
to pat ourselves on the back
more than more than often because
we're we're in a difficult phase and all
of those
all of those little tactics helped me
and
empathy of course everybody had them
had different challenges amazing so
on the sort of working from home pc my
second question for you is
what working from home tip could you
share with other recruiters listen to
this that's
had a real positive impact on your own
productivity when working from home
sure i think um the tips i would
have a plan the night before okay so
you need to make sure you're closing off
the day on a good note and you've got a
real sense of achievement that day
because otherwise you're going to be sat
there and even and thinking
what did i actually achieve so you know
make sure you finish on a high
if it's not a deal you know it's have
you learned and have you put yourself
in a great position within your business
for the next day
have a plan all set and ready so that
then you can have a bit of downtime in
the evening know how you'll hit it hard
the next day
and mindset positivity
what is going to put you in the best
frame of mind whilst at home
is it outdoors is it exercise are you
gonna get out on your bike at lunch time
are you gonna cram in a yoga session
before work you need coping mechanisms
because staying in the same
room under the same roof with the same
family or
or you know partner or children it will
drive you insane and that's completely
natural
so what are you going to do for yourself
what i struggle with is
i miss the morning commute now the
morning commute was for me it was time
to listen
to podcast have a read you know and have
a think
you know that's gone you basically throw
breakfast at the kids and run in the
room and get on a scrum
and so i i thought that's not working
for me so you know religiously in the
morning i'll get
get up go to the gym go running no
matter what the weather because
otherwise when do i get that
creativity thinking time yeah i love
that
so what i want to know next and i know
you've been on a bit of a transition but
i want to sort of ask over the whole 12
months to share what sort of comes up
for you but
what what's been the most effective way
for you to win business in the last 12
months either you personally or what
you've seen
through the teams that you've managed
perfect
okay so i think um first of all making
sure everybody
has a market is in a niche and they know
what they are trying to sell
okay and when you are at that point
understanding how you will map that out
and then learn how you will start to
capture a circle of influence whether
that is your
candidates or whether that's your
clients how can you bring some traffic
into you
what are you going to do every day that
will
you know you know i don't know um
make people think of you and land on
people's death you know a great email
speak to candidates give them that wow
factor service
and for me winning business in this
you know current day is about you know
giving them the x factor so
giving them what they can't find
themselves whether that's an amazing
candidate
or whether that's an amazing service
with a client
um and you know looking at the client's
roadmap for the next three months and
plug in where you can add value
more than ever it's about standing out
from the crowd
it's not enough now just to know your
market
you need to know your competition inside
out you need to follow them and you need
to know what they're doing
and you need to be very brave nice give
give them the x factor love that so
be interested to hear this from you what
what habit of hobby did you start in
2020 that you're going to continue in
2021
good question and always been a keen
runner and
i love my you know cycling as well and
my resistance training but
for me i really stepped up the running
this year so
now it's quite normal for me just to you
know
roll out of bed and do a do a 10k
basically what i said to myself is
um put on a podcast and
listen to audible download a great book
and
as long as it's an hour long gonna keep
running then yeah around 10k
got any any big running goals this year
that you want to share with us that
you're going to commit to
i think i'd like to try a half marathon
absolutely and i think i'd like to
yeah i'd like to push myself towards the
end of the year doing something like
that it's become the norm now and i'm
ready to go
got some got some new trainers so
i love that right so probably the most
important questions out of these seven
what do you think is better the first
coffee in the morning or the first pint
post work on a friday
seriously tough question
it's got to be a friday night it's got
to be a drink yeah it's gonna be a half
five half five
cold beer or um nice glass of prosecco
to toast the week
nice fair enough right so next question
slightly different it's a scenario which
i to sort of hear your thoughts on how
you'd approach it
so the scenario is a particular business
that you've been trying to get
sort of hold of they've been on your
target client list for quite a while
and during that that time they've been
on your target client list you've had
several touch points with different
people in that business that may have
seen your content on linkedin they've
engaged with it you may have sent a copy
of my message on linkedin or sent an
email
but you managed through your candidate
network to get one of the hiring
managers contact details
so i just want to sort of hear what you
do if
you call that person they pick up say
hello who is this
how would you approach that sort of
first interaction with that hiring
manager
sure okay and given the fact
that you've already learned about the
company i think
you'll be thrilled when you get this
person on the phone because what you're
going to do
you're going to draw on everything you
know about him
and his company to really spark his
his or her attention so the first thing
i want to do
i want to introduce myself and i want to
say
um you know i'm thrilled that i've got
you on the phone
and you know i'd really welcome a chat
to you about your business
so far i've learnt um
xyz so i'm going to go into the call
knowing has the company have any
investment in the last 12 months
how many hires have they made who in my
network have given me the heads up
they've been taken on
or or anything like that you know has
there been um
has there been any attrition have they
developed new products
i'm going into call with that knowledge
so i'm going to tell them i know that
and i'm going to say that i work with
their competitor
and i'm going to tell them all about the
great work that i'm doing for my clients
at the minute
now i'm coming across as credible
because i've done my reading
and my listening and i've also got a
good handle on the market
i appreciate where his company is
positioned and i'm showing them an
active interest in the product that
they're developing
the investment they've had or you know
news about them in the press you know
twitter
what has been out there from their
company and i think being inquisitive
and showed an active interest in them i
think that for me starts you out on the
wrong foot and of course
it ends up being a really really good
business conversation
and i love those types of interactions
and
and you know i'm not going to go in and
start um you know
selling in tvs my first call i think for
me spark interest
clarify that you know they are the right
person to speak to
and tell them all about the service that
i provide but finishing the call on a
high
with confidence with a call to action
and
you know you've had that dialogue so
much so that you can send a follow-up
email thank them for the time and say
you know what i'm even more interested
in you as a company now
you know i i think that's how i play it
and that's worked for me
in the past no i really like that i
actually
i can envision it now how thrilled you'd
come across and i think that
i think that's great and i really like i
really like the line around
and let me tell you what i've what i
know about you so far and showing that
active interest i really like i think
that's great advice
um final question so
i want you to sort of imagine that the
recruiters the obviously the recruiters
listening to this podcast
um you're speaking to someone that has
set their goals for 2021
they have written them down they're
feeling extremely motivated they want to
have a better year than they did last
year
and i just want to sort of hear what
your advice would be to the recruiters
listen to this that you think
would give them the best possible chance
of actually achieving the goals that
they've set
brilliant okay so for me um
you know it's a hard year you might have
made a plan and you're kind of veering
off track every now and then and you
know what that's quite normal so
the first thing is not to panic okay
and i think remember as well you know
you are the pilot
you are in control of your plan right
don't leap without a plan and certainly
don't leap without sharing it nobody
creates amazing work in isolation let's
be honest we want to take all the credit
for our work but come on we have to draw
on each other
and have the humility as well to know
you're not the finished article
if you plan your plan might be going on
track you might go off track
but but have humility to be able to
think you know what i'm learning
right um you've got a plan
you probably want to make more sales you
want to bring in revenue you want to
build a new customer base
okay so that's fine so obviously mapping
out your business
and knowing your niche looking at how
you can
shut out the noise on everything else
that's tempting
you know jobs that aren't in your path
or you know old relationships that you
know think they can give you a bit of
low-hanging fruit
be disciplined and you know have an
unflinching
belief in your service and what you can
offer
to your patch as soon as you start to
breathe that confidence
you start to step outside of yourself
and look
at how you want to be perceived and with
that
comes really confident conversations
with candidates
and clients where you can say look you
know i
am not a technical expert but i am
really really
invested in getting to know you in this
market more
what you look for in a person like me
you know this is what i look for in
someone like you and i i
started being really honest what that's
going to give you is great mapping great
control great conversations
you know conversations with candidates
you know you can turn them into critical
credible conversations with clients um
but yeah i'd say plan it plan
you know good plan share it be open to
learning you know all that growth
mindset
stuff and enjoy it
don't think that it's a to-do list
see it as a execution of what i know
i am capable love that
absolutely love your energy caroline
thank you
50 minutes 50 minutes with a mentor
thank you
brilliant thank you so much good luck